this is my be VAD doing campaign and I
want everyone to grow a pair I'm a [ __ ]
for peace not a piece of [ __ ]
the guys actually assaulted women he
invaded their space and he brags about
it and that makes me so angry
establish the velocity years are really
positive images are Sunday in general
and those from not only have enough more
quality experience but it's diplomacy
skills are minimal at best
so tests are great because they may
mother's voice really loud but they
don't actually necessarily accomplish
anything policy wise but what it does is
it shows me and us and everybody here
that homes of people care about the
things that we care about that we're not
alone and I think it does make us feel
like a more United States
the civilized ominous her life
libertarian they have formally kicked
out a new way feminist and fertilise
feminist out of the thirties ation but I
had feminists and libertarians we do not
include missus and we do not do many
people if feminists see that there are
free market feminists through life
feminists and they'll be willing to
engage in civil conversation with dozens
of Socrates
I was disturbed with the whole protest
that the women's March was again on
Zuckerberg and there right now under law
so it's not important to me even though
I'm a pastor's wife I'm not in favor of
prostitution and as a libertarian if
that's your choice
I think that all women and men for that
matter to have full protection of the
law early validating the halfway to
slaughter phobia and it's something
about understand age we can vilify
people by the beliefs that they hold
have a mission that they have and the
country of their home and how their name
sounds it is illegal to gray hair in
this dream tree in America black hair is
under attack and I was arrested in 97 my
livelihood was taken 20 years away from
me and then I'm just one my people
create their own occupation want to go
to work for whatever gear that they
naturally do if you have a license that
is government regulated then that sucks
the livelihood of someone like little
diddy me in a different franchise
community who just wants to uplift my
community and seize my own life children
so that's what i'll see
[Applause]
[Music]